où là il n'est pas passé loin celui ci
enfin bon tout est relatif l'astéroïde
1998 or deux c surnom est passé à 6,3
millions de km de la terre autrement dit
seize fois la distance terre-lune peux
vous donner une petite idée
au mois de juillet 2019 un autre
astéroïde s'est approché de la terre à
seulement 70 km il mesurait une centaine
de mètres celui qui vient de s'approcher
qui est plus volumineux il mesure
environ 2 km de diamètre alors il est
évident que si un caillou comme celui ci
venait à percuter la terre
on sentirait passé pour mémoire
l'astéroïde qui s'est abattue sur notre
planète il ya 65 millions d'années qui a
provoqué la disparition des dinosaures
mesurer une dizaine de kilomètres avec
eux 1998 or 2 nous n'avons absolument
rien à craindre
c'est un sujet parfait pour une capsule
de des confiné il appartient à un groupe
d'astéroïdes baptisé amor amour en
espagnol dont on connaît parfaitement la
trajectoire
elle frôle leur big de la terre sans
jamais d'y pénétrer
franchement y'a des trucs dont computer
dont il faut davantage se méfier et se
tenir à l'écart
si vous avez aimé cette capsule de déco
fine et n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus vous pouvez également voir ou
revoir celle des jours précédents qui
campent sur le côté gauche pendant le
confinement gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors le mieux pour ne pas
louper bien c'est de vous abonner qui
est activé la petite cloche aller à
demain
et n'oubliez pas nous sommes toujours
confiné mais en restant bien